in 387 years only two women have been
president of Harvard University one the
first woman was before Claud and gay
only one black woman has been president
let's go over to the televised mental
institution known as
MSNBC uh because of course they're
blaming I think the gotcha mentality
though is in fact the point let's just
be very clear the testimony from the
president's horrific so they they
horrific it was absolutely terrible they
answered a human question with an
academic answer uh that they were
prepped by their universities quite
frankly to give so that's law firms
terrible staff work okay across the
board but on top of that what happened
in the aftermath of that particularly as
it relates to Dr Gay uh the calls came
and said she was terrible in this
hearing and she's unqualified in 387
years only two women have been president
of Harvard University one the first
woman was before Claud and gay only only
one black woman has been president and
that black woman now 6 months after uh
has resigned from her job because in
look at the statement it's in the best
interest of Harvard to resign so the
community can navigate with focus on the
institution rather than an individual
Harvard decided that it was unweathered
to un unable to continue to weather the
storm and while I don't think the
culture wars frankly that play out on
campuses across the country will
eventually have a the biggest effect in
general come 2024 what will have an
effect as to Doug said is how Jewish
students feel on college campuses how
Arab American students feel on college
campuses and how every black
professional in America can turn on
their television today see this news
about Dr Claud and gay and and all have
the same reaction it looks it it it
looks as though she was targeted it's
interesting stuff you said she was
horrific and then we had a series of
scandals she's she then targeted herself
again she was worse than fighters
in testifying before Congress I mean I
guess I guess I will just say this is
that you know again 387 years I much
like when we talked about classified
documents with former presidents vice
presidents and I have said you know
there's no protocol in which to pack up
a a president or vice president Le's
office and I think if you go to any home
of a former president or vice president
you might accidentally find a classified
document or two not necessarily nuclear
secrets but you know maybe a piece of
paper that they shouldn't have took out
same thing look at all what other
presidents of Harvard have been
investigated for plagiarism and if we
want to be very specific which I think
we should they the the issues of
plagiarism it is loose citations again
not something I want I to do but I'm
just all I'm
saying old
fash there's so much there it's like
what do you what do we even do with this
but it's not plagiarism guys it's loose
citations they rewrite history right in
front of us in real time it's
extraordinary imagine if a kid at
Harvard it doesn't even matter what
discipline they were in hands in a paper
and there's a whole bunch of stuff that
they just copied and pasted they didn't
plagiarize it they just copied and
pasted they borrowed ideas they Loosely
this and that you would be kicked out of
school so she's just resigning and now
will be a professor of political science
of course of course political science uh
there's a whole bunch of other stuff
there I don't know exactly what uh
Simone Sanders was trying to say about
how uh Jewish and Arab students are now
going to feel on those campuses but the
idea that somehow again they're going
after her because she's black I no
problem if you if somebody out there if
Simone or any of you people who are
always trying to tell us all how racist
we are why don't you guys do some
digging and every white College
president who has done the level of
plagiarism that uh Claudine gay has done
should step down or should at least be
exposed and then the school can decide
what to do right like of course this has
nothing to do with racism and again Liz
Mill you pen she already stepped down
but what did I say was the the theme of
the show today the theme of the show is
that when you get these wins right when
you blow up an absolute fraud and
grifter like Jen yuger as Douglas Murray
did or you get a win by having the
plagiarist let's say qu at least
somewhat racist or just deeply stupid
because of intersectionality Claudine
gay have to resign when you get some of
these wins you got to keep going right
there's an inclination to just take your
foot off the pedal and be like oh we got
a couple wins you want to have lunch but
you got to keep going because we
actually are in a culture War right
now